foreign
[Music]
on The View yesterday I just want to
play this for you it's not exactly a
lead headline but uh they were talking
about all this yesterday and and uh
Jesus you know it's it's one thing to
defame Libs of tick tock or me or
Christopher or Donald Trump or you know
one of The Usual Suspects that's one
thing
um of course infinitely more outrageous
and offensive is when they try to drag
Jesus Christ into this which is what
they did on The View listen to this
they were in a place that accepts them
for who they were and someone came to
that place
I don't know that they hide behind
religion because I said this on this
show once before Jesus would be the
Grand Marshal at the pride parade I
don't mean about gay people I mean in
every argument we have but here's the
weaponized religion but it's wrong if
you're so afraid why are you going over
there yeah if they scare you so much
leave them alone when stuff scares me I
leave it alone if I don't want to be
bothered I don't go there see that's the
problem you don't want to just have your
feelings you want everybody else to join
you and you know what you can you can
scream you can cuss you can do all the
things that you say but you know what
gay people are here they're not going
anywhere there is nothing you can do you
know you can yell and scream but you
know as as the Lord as everybody was
talking about you know made in God's
image yep made in God's image there are
no but except for there's none of that
no keep that in mind when you're trying
to figure out where you stand as a human
being let alone a Christian we'll be
right back what I really appreciate is
that the one check at the beginning
starts by saying
um and I honestly don't know any of
their names except for Whoopi Goldberg
enjoy it so I know those two I don't
know the other however many it is
um the chick at the beginning says that
their weaponizing religion they use
religion and then for the rest of the
segment all the other women on the panel
do what she just accused conservatives
of doing they start using religion to
weaponize it against their opponents so
they're like contradicting exactly what
she just said
[Music]
so the women over on The View were um
squawking this week about free speech
and I want to go through
a couple of these clips first of all
here's Whoopi Goldberg announcing
um tragically that she's leaving Twitter
look over Twitter and the places that
it's a mess he's already called back
some of the workforce he fired a few
days ago he's putting his Eight dollar
charge for blue check verification on
hold first it was going to be twenty
dollars now it's going to be eight
dollars he also suspended Kathy Griffin
for impersonating him on a parody
account uh which has started a free
Cappy hashtag to Trent I mean I'm I'm I
I'm getting off I'm getting off today
because I just feel like you know it's
it's so messy yeah and I I'm tired of
now
having had certain kinds of attitudes
blocked and now they're back on and I
just I'm gonna get out and if it settles
down and I feel more comfortable yeah
maybe I'll come back but as of tonight
I'm done with Twitter
of course Mo if you're like me you hear
that and you think uh uh oh you were on
Twitter I didn't even know that like
what are the what are the I I just want
to know in if I can get in their own
head get in their heads which is not
really a place I'd want to be but well
how do you think people are going to
react to this do you think people are
you're making some big dramatic
announcement I'm done you know I might
be back later but I just for now I'm out
of there which by the way when it comes
to dramatic announcements that's uh
that's that's
kind of an anticlimactic way to go about
it
I'm done I mean I might come back later
but I'm done for now I will not be on
Twitter again until at least tomorrow
morning if not a little bit sooner but
at this moment right now I'm not gonna
be I am not using Twitter at this moment
while I'm on TV
what do they expect do they think that
people are gonna
like the people think it's good that
Elon Musk took over Twitter are they
gonna say well never mind I mean if this
scares uh Whoopi Goldberg away I can't
imagine Twitter without Whoopi Goldberg
[Music]
so The View
you know if you tune into the view
whoever makes the mistake of doing that
um maybe
I don't know I don't know what you're
expecting when it comes to something
like this I don't know if you're
expecting
in real insight into uh into geopolitics
from the ladies of the view but if
that's what you're looking for you're
going to be disappointed
um here is Joy Behar what's what's her
main you know concern what is she
worried might happen if this um if this
conflict spreads and becomes a World War
yeah there's global warming but as far
as she's concerned there's um a
consequence even more dire than that
listen
estimates are 50 000 ukrainians will be
dead or wounded yeah and that this is
going to start a humanitarian crisis a
refugee crisis in Europe we're talking
about five million people that that are
going to be displaced I mean it's it's
heartbreaking to hear what is going to
happen yeah well I'm scared of what's
going to happen in in Western Europe too
yeah you know you just you plan a trip
you want to go there I want to go to
Italy for four years I haven't been able
to make it because of of uh the pandemic
and now this you know it's it's like
who's gonna what's gonna happen there
and now this
first there was a pandemic a five
million people died and stopped me from
taking it to my my Italy vacation that
I've wanted to take it's been my dream
and now we have War what else what else
is going to happen to me is Joy bear
all right moving to this Whoopi Goldberg
is uh shedding some some light adding
some insight to the Nancy Pelosi
communion situation in San Francisco
let's listen to that
welcome to the view y'all the abortion
rights battle is starting to blur the
lines between church and state the
Archbishop of San Francisco
[Applause]
is calling for speaker Nancy Pelosi to
be denied receiving communion because of
her pro-choice stance he's one of the
priests who also called for President
Biden be denied Sacrament this is not
your job dude that is not you can't that
is not up to you to make that decision
you know what is the saying it's kind of
amazing uh
but you know
what is the point of communion right
it's for uh Sinners it's the for the for
Sinners it's the reward of saints but
the bread of Sinners how dare you
it's not your job dude
no uh Whoopi that is
literally his job it's actually what
what he is supposed to do as the
Archbishop
okay now
and I just does Whoopi Goldberg identify
herself as Catholic I'm not actually
sure about that
whether she identifies herself that way
or not as a soft in the case these days
on the left with self-identification
it's it's false it doesn't mean anything
because she clearly whether she's
Catholic or not does not understand the
basic hierarchical structure of the uh
of of the church and by the way there is
no mixing of church and state here at
all
okay in fact if if the Archbishop had
declined to enforce the rules for Nancy
Pelosi because she's a high-ranking
government official that would be
church and state
[Music]
it's always kind of cheap and easy to
use a segment from The View as fodder
for the daily cancellation and it is
definitely cheap and easy but sometimes
it's okay to go the cheap and easy
directional life I think so we turn now
to these screeching banshees of the view
as they discuss Mike Pence and his views
on marriage during the Q a his most
recent yeah speech Pence addressed his
support for so-called traditional
marriage Otherwise Known simply as
marriage but addressed it in a
relatively sort of circumspect way let's
watch that
if one of your children came out to you
as gay how would you respond what would
you tell them
I'd look him in the eye and tell him I
love you
I believe marriage was ordained by God
and instituted in the law
but we live in a pluralistic society
and the way we go forward
and the way we come together as a
country United
I believe is when we respect
your right to believe and my right to
believe what we believe
a political answer mostly meaningless
but I'm not going to harp on that you
know we actually aren't going to come
together as a country United simply by
respecting each other's right to believe
whatever we believe I mean we obviously
all have the right to believe what we
believe
you can't stop somebody from believing
something
even in like North Korea you technically
have the right to believe whatever you
want to believe because no one can get
inside your mind and stop you from
believing anything
um but acknowledging that we all have
the ability to believe whatever we want
to believe is not itself the basis for
any sort of meaningful National Unity
and though I do acknowledge other
people's right to believe whatever they
believe I certainly don't respect
the beliefs themselves necessarily
true National Unity could be forged
through shared belief
not shared acknowledgment of everybody's
right to believe what they believe but
through actually sharing in the same
fundamental values and beliefs not that
everyone's marching lockstep and
believes all the exactly the same things
on every single point but having some
basic fundamental values and beliefs in
common
that's where you have Unity
because then you're uniting around that
you take that away then what are you
uniting around there's nothing there
um I don't share the beliefs of the
other side in this country and I also
don't respect their beliefs and I find
their beliefs to be abhorrent insane and
disgusting so much so that I actually
don't even respect them personally
either
so that's the situation
in any case this is all sum up beside
the point I suppose the heckling
heritans on the panel weren't discussing
that issue exactly instead they offered
their insights about the marriage issue
and um so we're gonna we're gonna go
through just a brief sampling of this
first up is the token fake conservative
at the table
um Alyssa Farah who used to work for
Pence and um here's what she says and
some of the other women
I still advise a number of Republicans
um and one issue that I have or two
issues I've told them across the board
you will lose the younger generation 35
and down is if you do not come around on
marriage equality and climate change the
country's Mind Is Made Up I'm someone
who believes you can believe what you
want in your church I'm Episcopalian I
have certain beliefs in my church but it
is the law of the land that you can
marry who you love and that is a good
thing having the right to choose who you
want to be and not being made to feel
shame is what democracy is who decided
that at traditional marriage is a man
and a woman who came up with this plan
well everything that exists in nature
right people say it's unnatural but
isn't everything that exists
by definition it is natural but is
homosexuality even mentioned in the
Bible I don't think it is
you know um I I appreciate what you're
saying about about your former boss and
Mike Pence I I think he's lying on that
um and I I think that you know words are
meaningless when your actions say
differently right and um let's just take
a look very briefly at Mike Pence's
record with the lgbtq uh plus Community
um in 2000
um he uh said during his Congressional
Campaign that Congress should oppose any
effort to put gay and lesbian
relationships on an equal legal status
with heterosexual marriage
now I have to check so don't quote me on
this but I think that the clip you just
watched actually now holds the record as
in fact officially the dumbest 90
seconds in the history of Television
there's a lot of competition for the
title but the sheer amount of dumb
packed into such a short period of time
creates an incredibly and perhaps
historically and maybe fatally potent
concentration of dumbness
so let's try to our best to kind of sort
through it all starting at the beginning
first the pretend conservative says that
she is still advising Republicans now I
wish I could just assume that she's
lying about that but unfortunately I
have no doubt that um any number of
Republicans would be foolish enough to
take political advice from a talking
head on The View I could definitely see
somebody like Adam kinsinger maybe
Utah's Governor Spencer Cox paying money
to hear the sage wisdom of Joy behar's
TV sidekick
and the primary piece of wisdom she
offers to these poor dull-witted saps is
that the best way to win the Young
Generation is to give up defending
marriage in the family and to become a
climate change alarmist
she didn't say it there but I can
guarantee she would also advise that
Republicans lay off the pro-life stuff
maybe start adopting some Pro CRT
talking points take a friendliest
friendlier stance towards gender
ideology learn to love gun control
in fact I'm positive on that last point
because apparently during another
segment on the show she conceded that no
one needs an AR-15 quote unquote
um another concession to impress young
people I suppose
well the problem is that you aren't
going to win the young over to your side
or anyone over to your side
by becoming a pale imitation of your
opponents
why would any young person go to the
Republican party to get their
progressivism fixed when they could just
go to the Democrats and get the real
stuff pure grade right from the source
what are they going to choose organic
grass-fed leftism or watered-down
pre-packaged leftism with artificial
flavoring
next we hear from the other woman who
says that democracy is the right to
choose who you want to be without
feeling shame
no part of that is true or makes sense
you don't have the universal absolute
right to choose who you want to be
whatever that even means and you
certainly don't have the right to not
feel shame
now shame may be warranted or not the
person causing you to feel shame may be
justified or not depending on the
circumstances But whichever is the case
you can't claim from the universe the
right to be free from shame or judgment
or criticism
there's no government in the world that
can protect you from those aspects of
life
nor should the government try
speaking of the government none of this
has anything to do with democracy
democracy is a political system which
comes in various forms direct democracy
representative democracy and so on but
democracy is not the overarching
catch-all term that people seem to want
to turn it into
when somebody says democracy these days
what they really mean is stuff that I
like
whatever they like or want is democracy
whatever they don't like or don't want
is anti-democratic
which is totally nonsensical
then to top it all off she said she
claims that anything which can be found
in nature is natural now
this is technically true as the word
natural can be defined as existing in
nature but
just because something exists in nature
or can be found in nature that in and of
itself doesn't mean that it's good
cancer is natural in that sense it
exists in nature cannibalism exists in
nature murder
uh non-consensual sex happens all over
the animal kingdom
you're really walking down a precarious
path when you try to morally justify
something by pointing out that it occurs
in nature
you need to offer more than that
after all the whole reason the law
exists is that we are naturally inclined
to behave in immoral ways if we weren't
then there'd be no need for any law at
all
after that Joy Behar says that
homosexuality isn't in the Bible
and she's right
about that
of course I mean aside from First
Corinthians 6 Leviticus 20 Romans 126
First Timothy Romans 1 27 numerous other
passages but aside from all that it's
not in there
finally the other din bulb at the table
gets a chance to chime in and Begins by
pointing out that Mike Pence opposed gay
marriage in the year 2000.
you know who else suppose gay marriage
in the year 2000
um Barack Obama
Hillary Clinton
the entire Democratic Party
the vast majority of the country and
nearly the entire world outside of this
country
like they all did too
at that time
this is actually a significant point
that she raises inadvertently you know
because it does bring to mind the fact
that just a couple of decades ago nearly
everyone everywhere believe that
marriage was between a man and a woman a
decade and a half later that view had
become not only unpopular but
unspeakable another five years after
that and nobody even knows what a man or
woman is anymore
might this be evidence of
I don't know a slippery slope
worth thinking about
the thought process that may be beyond
the capacities of the ladies of the view
because it is a thought process that
involves you know
thought so instead they just Babble
nonsensically and that's why as easy as
it is to say I will still say that today
the view is canceled